c'était fait des grands mots michel
david michel sauget
qu'est ce qui arrive avec notons de 55
56 58 ans touchant appelé quand même pas
vécu 58 le pont allait le lait l'eau
tourte sur un point important
transcanadienne vauvert vous le
connaissez pour sortir de montréal pour
rentrer de l ouest
et là il est regardé ça vient d'arriver
et il est totalement fermée il y avait
on laissait déjà entrés vers lille c'est
terminé il est fermé fermé fermés un
petit monde chez elle c'est chez vous
aimez ces sujets là pourquoi pourquoi
les ponts bâtis à 55 ans ça fonctionne
plus un bon entretien
si le prochain plaît elle a été
entretenue comme du rhône il serait
encore là et on a dû le fermer que
l'entretien était mal fait qu' il y
avait été mal dessinée aussi à cause de
l'hiver est tout chaud mais elle a fait
une question d'entretien pour des moto2
c'est pareil c'est une question de
l'entretien
le ministère des transports il faut le
dire si mauvais que ça vous inspire
michel et ses fans vous n'êtes pas
obligé même chaîne
les ponts c'est le même problème avec
les écoles c'est un problème avec les
hôpitaux là il ya eu une espèce de
palmarès du mauvais entretien qui a été
présenté récemment des fois ça a des
conséquences catastrophiques l'on se
souvient tous du viatique de du pont de
la concorde où vraiment il y avait eu
mort quelque 2 ou 3 mois je pense
alors c'est ce que michel dit c'est
qu'on le pende entretenu d'une fois à
l'autre il ya d'autres priorités
intertoto d'un tournant important quand
je travaillais à ottawa puis j'ai fait
cette je sais que j'ai fait cette route
souvent montréal ottawa et il n'y avait
que des travaux sur ce pont là tout le
temps on en a même volé largement des
enfin quelque chose de mystérieux dans
ma tête stéphanie ouais mais je dirais
comme comme je le disais il ya eu un
déficit chronique d'entretien et pas
seulement pour les ponts québec fait le
bilan et puis on voit qu'il est
vaste pas d'actifs qui sont dans un état
un état pitoyable ou au québec
mais ce qui est malheureux c'est que
quand on tarde à faire l'entretien mais
plus ça va plus ça coûte cher
donc ça serait logique de faire les
travaux au fur et à mesure plutôt que
d'être obligé de réparer comme on l'a vu
avec le pont champlain moussa coûté des
fortunes alors qu'on savait qu'on était
déjà obligé de bâtir un nouveau pont
d'enfants ont nommé on est dans une
situation où on fait on a dès qu'on
arrange un peu partout alors fais ni
2009 et d'émilie tout coûte cher donc on
essaie de rattraper mais c'est pas
évident on peut pas mettre ça sur le dos
de nom mais à quelqu'un qui nous avons
rien au très drôle hazza on veut un
tunnel enfin sonné ok le béton c'est
peut-être pas si bon que ça non plus
regardez le très beau projet quartier
qui est encore totalement fonctionnel et
qui est offerte à métaux qui vient
piquer ticket droit tu nages j'ai les
crocs
il cache sa cause d'une expropriation
quelqu'un n'a pas voulu laisser son
terrain c'est pour ça que on a dû faire
une corde à noeuds pons ok les
frontières parlant de choses bloqué on a
reconduit d'une autre un autre mois
stéphanie je commence avec vous est ce
qu'il y aura pas de plus en plus de
pression pour qu'on rouvre à caen qu'on
assouplissent ce qui se passe à la
frontière canado américaine
mais c'est clair le sait ça va devenir
un enjeu plus la campagne de vaccination
avance et plus l'été approche parce que
pour les industries touristiques pour
l'industrie du transport aérien
et c'est évidemment le des sommes
importantes qui sont pas en jeu
alors si on obtient des résultats
encourageants du côté de la vaccination
c'est sûr que plus ça va aller
et plus on voit maintenant il va y avoir
de la pression parce que les gens vont
vouloir peut-être sortir impôts pour
l'été elle est sur les planches du
manager terrain mais on est encore
seulement autour de 2 47% noir canada et
aux états unis
ça c'est intéressant de le dire le conte
est pratiquement nez à nez parce que les
américains nous avait un peu marre il en
disant qu'on était en retard mais donc
presque la moitié de la population
vaccinée première dose de parts et
d'autres
sauf que le gouvernement trudeau sans me
dire que faudrait qu'on soit 75% plus
tôt pour ouvrir les frontières donc
encore un grand bout de chemin à faire
et aux états unis on voit que il ya plus
de récalcitrants l'a donc est-ce qu'ils
vont réussir à aller chercher à la fois
l'adhésion
malgré le fait qu'ils offrent toutes
sortes de cadeaux là pour convaincre les
gens d'aller se faire vacciner
donc puis je pense que habituellement ça
va passer peut-être par un passeport
vaccinale c'est une solution qui se met
en branle à l'échelle mondiale donc est
ce que notre preuve qu'on expose
avançons un téléphone cellulaire va être
la cli et qui va permettre d'ouvrir les
frontières ccc franco c'est parce que
bon job celle d'avesnes chassions j'aime
celle d'abord david un coup de gens qui
se chauffent peu près faire trois quatre
mois comme ça non moi j'ai l'impression
que c'est le dans le dernier report là
j'ai comme le sentiment qu'à partir du
21 juin
les français avons ouvrir comme disait
stéphanie il ya beaucoup de gens qui
attendent de se lancer à odos hatcher de
même d'aller faire du magasinage à plat
ce bug
je pense que c'est la dernière l'a
maintenant le taux de vaccination ils
sont quand même en avance sur la
deuxième dose aux états unis qui précède
il faudrait que ces traits sénégal aussi
les états frontaliers du québec la
vaccination va plutôt bien
mais il ya d'autres morceaux disons de
la frontière canadienne où la situation
aux états unis dans des états
républicains particulier voit moins bien
toi michel le virus il l'est toujours
d'ailleurs
alors les tous les côtés de la frontière
tous les jours
il faudrait voir ces américains sont
prêtes à les ouvrir la frontière aussi
parce que ça se joue à deux et les deux
gouvernements peuvent apporter le
l'autre des complications à ça alors
nous on a le même goût mais c'est
peut-être le code et les restaurateurs
de pratique je ne sais pas l'eau mais
tout est plus copié gatcha de joie on
verra pour les règles de quarantaine à
ce qu elles seront assouplies ou pas il
ya déjà eu vol en europe vont revenir
monsieur trudeau doit parler demain donc
on verra demain par ailleurs est-ce que
le financement du tunnel va devenir la
prochaine chicane michèle dawe aides
fédérales provinciales
j'ai l'impression que oui d'accord que
bon là il ya un contexte électoral qui
vont peut-être nous ont amené les gens à
m de part et d'autre de l'eau dans leur
vin mais mais là le gouvernement fédéral
je pense et est assez sur une position
assez solide là aux dernières nouvelles
il accepterait de financer la partie
transports en commun de du projet
c'est-à-dire essentiellement de deux
voies d'autobus dans le tunnel ce qui
représenterait à peu près 10% sur sur 10
milliards ça fait pas beaucoup si on
compare par exemple avec le tramway à
québec où je pense le gouvernement
fédéral le finage qu'à hauteur de 43
là il ya william mathias est clair que
le gouvernement legault va être votre
déçu et fâché mais je pense que
l'opinion publique à l'extérieur de la
région de québec va trouver que le
gouvernement fédéral d'une bonne cause
là dedans que ce tunnel l'a1 devrait pas
être construits et encore moins financés
par des programmes qui sont en principe
destinés à des infrastructures vertes
welch a surgi stx et rentrent pas dans
un programme d'un transport collectif le
gros en tout cas de l'addition alors
qu'est ce qu'on fait les conservateurs
ont déjà dit aujourd'hui d'argent québec
nous on va vous aider on vous aiderez
non oui bien sûr quand on veut avoir des
côtés et c'est pour ça qu'on va se
retrouver avec une exigence fait parce
que je suis le groupe de produits pour
avoir décompté dans la région de québec
comme jadis on avait promis d'acheter un
jeu de toute façon la moitié des alevis
tout le monde en deux exemples mais la
réalité c'est que y'a rien qui justifie
10 milliards d'investissements ou 55 et
une voiture ça c'est l'estimation de
monsieur bonnardel actuellement que
beaucoup de gens disent que c'est trop
ça c'est la moitié de ce qui passe super
bien là bas on peut pas je suis 10
milliards de dollars et le gouvernement
fédéral david a bien raison on va avoir
des amis pour votre joie à dire non à
québec parce que tu y avoir rajouté une
voix déservir des autobus c'est pas un
projet mais je pense que c'est ça c'est
un peu de la poudre aux yeux parce que
on s'entend que c'est pour faire
circuler des voitures on a beau dire que
ce soit des voitures électriques un jour
mais quand même là c'est c'est pas un
projet de relance verte le pas du tout
c'est plutôt à un projet qui va amener
encore plus d'automobilistes sur les
routes parce qu'on aussi que quand on
entend augmenter la capacité quand on
crée des ponts des autoroutes ça fait
juste amener plus de véhicules donc de
l'étalement urbain et donc de la
pollution et
et on a un gouvernement qui nous promet
une relance verte c'est pas dans cette
direction là que ça s'en va et il y
aurait des solutions de transport en
commun possible loufoque mais la
possibilité de faire un téléphérique
entre lévis et québec
et quand même quelque chose qui peut
être explorées ça coûterait infiniment
moins cher ça prendrait moins de temps
mettra en place sa transe portrait plus
de personnes ou moins donné oui pour
pour les autres ça c'est certain que
c'est moins pratique
mais par contre ce serait du transport
en commun et les gens qui prendraient ce
téléphérique lot désengorgerait les
pompes à ce qui serait plus sur les
routes
je pense qu'on vivra pas assez vieux
pour voir monsieur legault annoncé un
téléphérique entre lévis québec parce
qu'ils se faire michel singh devait
réagir aussi les téléphériques 84 euros
1 parle de ce beat sud dans un corps et
d'urbanisme déjà rigolo parce que c'est
pas très pratique ça cache souvent il ya
divers ça va être sur le fleuve va
prendre ce regrettable alors je pense
sûr que ça peut rappeler c'est un vrai
système de transport en commun
cela dit on peut essayer d'autres choses
soient surveillés que j'ai fait oui
michel av desk néanmoins monsieur
trudeau n'est pas un peu embêté parce
que là ça va devenir une pression énorme
monsieur duclos a réagi aujourd'hui par
citation on va le monter aucun projet
officiel n'a encore été présentée au
gouvernement fédéral pour analyse
et là il ya un peu de zéro nid a dit
nous avons hâte écrit-il monsieur du
clos de recevoir une proposition
officielle du gouvernement du québec
ainsi que tous les détails du projet en
matière de transport collectif le
transport collectif alors mai et michel
avait n'est-il pas quand même un peu
embêté monsieur trudeau parce que là il
ya des élections qui se pointe le nez
vernon à quel point je pense que
monsieur trudeau une bonne position
d'abord michel de 10 à québec les gens
sont partagés c'est pas sur la rive sud
je pense que monsieur trudeau à ce pas
faire des gains et d'autre part le bloc
vous savez on a été très bon là dedans
au début ils ont dit bon bah ça ça
regarde québec
et puis on est satisfait de voir que des
équipements verts là dedans mais tout le
monde voit que c'est de la foutaise et
n'a pas vraiment des équipements verts
et mais je sais pour revenir sur la
question de ce téléphérique
ça peut paraître un peu loufoque mais je
me souviens que jean garon lui à
l'époque proposait un métro puis je me
suis en train de me demander son arrêt
produits de l'écouté ça s'arrête déjà
j'en garde ou ailleurs oui oui tout à
fait lunetterie québec et lévis un
tunnel mais un tunnel de transport en
commun pour un tunnel pour les voitures
et il ya été ridiculisé à l'époque mais
à bien y repenser peut être aussi faut
parfois il a fallu le faire à ce moment
là est-ce que vous pensez que finalement
contenu tout seul tout ce qu'on a
entendu quelques jours que c'est fort
possible que ça ne se fasse pas c'est
fanny tour de temps ben moi je pense que
c'est ce que ça serait une bonne chose
que ça ait pas de l'avant est ce qui
manque à québec c'est du transport en
commun et pas des autoroutes pas des
tunnels est donc aussi nos québec c'est
de toutes les grandes villes canadiennes
l'une de celles où les gens empruntent
le moins de transports en commun mais
évidemment c'est la 9 et la poule 6 en a
pas ils peuvent pas le prendre mais deux
fois moins qu'à montréal mais moins que
dans l'alberta calgary edmonton
donc c'est là qu'il faut mettre le
paquet le sillon que michel a même songé
parce que les la vice-première mené ça
dit en conférence de presse qu'elle a
annoncé le projet avec monsieur legault
comprenait pas besoin des gens de
montréal nous on a le droit n'est pas du
gâteau gros projets enfin il ya beaucoup
de projets sur lesquels on pourrait
investir là mais ça va se faire là pour
répondre à monsieur le bourg et que le
repas là dessus ça me parait passable
beaucoup portent trop engagé et il y
aura qu il s'est excusé une coupe deux
fois par an on fait des erreurs mais
celle là je pense qu'il est il un être à
jamais qui chassait tout projet qui
tient sur trois mandats de gouvernement
est susceptible d'être mulet un moment
donné les michèle dawe et de raison chez
legault s'était passé beaucoup trop sur
ce vidéo pour le faire la seule chose
qui peut arriver c'est effectivement que
le gouvernement fédéral d'un petit peu
d'argent que là ils vont peut-être pas
assez à deux fois maintenant il ya sur
son propre projet alors qu'un autre 14
mai banal guilbaud mais tout à fait
raison c'est une histoire de gâteaux à
québec stéphanie michel michel c'est
merci beaucoup
à très bientôt pour voir nos émissions
en entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici
et redit